hello and welcome to this video playing
the Yardbird grant master Eric LeBron
I'm playing something else just for the
sake of it just get a different kind of
position for once - four is masculine
29 wins 33 losses heaven false 69 games
quite something
playing for c4 in this position very
good yeah I can get him to take on d5
with the pawn that would be nice oh hi
okay let's play not interesting
I want to say play it simple but hmm
that's not so amazing I didn't want to
take him okay but probably there is no
big choice here yeah it's a French type
of position in some way I've got this
nice square there on b5 not sure that it
helps so much but it's good to have it
but it's not quite clear if I have some
benefiting so much from it yeah I can
double up but it's not helping I don't
know probably not much
so over at five him I would want to play
Bishop g4 I don't mind dad
trade that's thing he's got that fire
though yeah maybe yeah maybe this is
what's going for taking
I basically shuffled around gym
hi this is how it gets through catch six
I simply I simply didn't see that so
easy oh my god okay now it just has to
Kyle up on edge too somehow and will win
I have no motion can never take because
I've got no square for the night it's
almost looks one can go to this seven
here can play night eight seven maybe
not sure if the sacrifice 24 really wins
hmm I was a terribly played here I had
no idea whatsoever in this position I
was just shuffling around without any
purpose
possible we need the idea for blankets
to make a battery on h2 and just chick
made me like this question is can you do
it
I'm currently controlling stuff here
currently I don't see how he wins I mean
it looks bad yeah the sacrifice doesn't
doesn't do anything so he wants to try
with an ending here
yeah that's it's definitely an idea time
warning
also checking f5 not sure that I'm
really threatening to take it maybe but
probably he always has Queen to see once
I'm not not attacking it for real maybe
if the king is on g1 or so I think if it
is to take it I'm drawing this position
unless I'm getting into some weird suits
one
I now we can take and play the Queen
over hide your tick so idiotic it's so
simple just pay a little bit of
attention please no just awful I mean of
course I deserve to lose this game
because I played it like a complete
[ __ ] but still check
check-check
I'm two pieces down to pieces it's a bit
much
check sail mates check
and that's still winning check check
okay I mean he will lose real winner on
time but it wasn't necessary that he
gives me like a million pawns It's Made
on edge too
the bishop is on a six what a bad game
Wow really not in good shape today
you know he lets the clock run down
before he plays out the meter what's the
idea
checkmate okay whatever
yeah Oh what did that happen is this
position so bad
it's hard to believe I feel so this
should be kind of okay it's just
completely passive I was mostly
accelerating is play around
I wasn't still I wasn't sure that I need
to lose this here anymore after I got
started trade it maybe it's still bad
okay now Queen b6 is okay which I didn't
see Queen d2 was supposed to not lose
what's the difference
okay I can go here no didn't quite
understand the engine here it was just
just a very bad barely played game I
thought I have some play on the C file I
know that this is kind of normal this is
what white usually does in this opening
but this year already looked look wrong
can also take in here which is probably
better even
but the way it was it was kind of yeah
very uncomfortable also resembled
something from some reversed French
position edge and simply hate to play
him and this space disadvantage now that
didn't work out well played it really
badly
ok thanks for watching